[Music]
joy is in cincinnati hey joy what's up
hi i am so honored thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up dave and
dr johnny i
am a retired law enforcement officer i
get a pension
but i listened to dave ramsey and i went
back to work part time so actually i'm
sitting in the parking lot right now
getting ready to go in
um and every time i want to
quit i keep ain't nope dave will say no
anyway my husband was a was an active
duty um well career marine
he also retired uh he gets a pension
but he does have a lot of service
related problems he did get a full-time
job with the post office but it just got
so bad on him he had to quit his
full-time job
with them we still get a pension but
we're struggling just you know i want to
get us out of debt and i'm i'm
struggling i should say what's your
question for our run out of time
i'm sorry
we have a 19 year old son at home he's
our only child we started late
my husband treats him
like he's still six my husband's the
heart marshmallow i'm the mean one
i want him to get out of the house get a
job and help you know if he's going to
stay there i want him to pay
like almost rent
and he won't he won't get out of his
room he sits on his computer and plays
games i don't want him to hate me
because i have to be the mean one to get
him to do something
your husband's the main one yeah your
husband's handicapping that poor boy
hurting him
he doesn't see it that way and my
husband also has traumatic brain injury
so
i'm walking on eggshells with that ptsd
traumatic brain injury so if you take
your 19 year old and you tell him that
he's got
30 days or 60 days or 90 days to go find
a job and get out he's going to be mad
at you and he's going to say mean things
if you let him live there till he's 30
then he's going to hate you when he was
four and you made him brush his teeth he
got mad too
and it was the right thing to do but we
still made him brush his freaking teeth
that's right because we love him and he
needs teeth when he's older
it feels like he might be a blanket a
security blanket for your husband right
now and i'm not saying that facetiously
i get that he he's a
he's a probably a therapy pet for your
husband right now right he's somebody
that that your husband can count on
he's gone no no he's got to get out
stays in his room
he needs to get up and listen he stays
in his room because you all allow it and
stays in his room because you all allow
it right it's got to stay it's got to
stop
you need to move out mom yeah
you gotta love him enough to move him
out
he needs to get his time it's time he's
functioning on a 14 year old level
because you're letting him
and it's not going to work out well
because he's not ever he's never going
to meet the special someone because
they're not going to come to his room